come together muslim-made once again to
get to clean water families in gaza
105 pounds can provide interrupted water
to two families
for an entire year do you choose to wear
the hijab no
you don't no do you choose to wear the
hijab
so so why do you wear it why are they so
threatened
by a mere hijab that these sisters so we
are here in the french soil
and we are telling you get your hands
off
our sister's hijab
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
what am i doing here sitting down on
stairs
and who are these two hijabis well one
of them is
my wife and the other one is my
sister-in-law my wife's sister
now the reason we're here today in the
french embassy brothers and sisters is
to highlight a very
important issue what is that issue now
brothers and sisters what we need to
understand is that the european high
court
has given a verdict and what's that
verdict
that muslim women cannot wear their
hijab in the workplace
anymore why the question that we need to
ask ourselves
is why is it that the european union
or the western world be it france
austria germany and different countries
have a problem with us uh with the
muslim women and the hijab
why are they so threatened by a mere
hijab that these
sisters my wife and her sisters wearing
what
is the biggest threat that concerns you
so much
that you want to take away from them
what is it
you're trying to sexualize them degrade
them
and brothers and sisters this is this
shows you
how powerful and this is a direct
message to my sisters that are watching
this
they want to strip you starting from
your head
all the way down to your toes why
because they want to make you feel as if
you're being liberated
and we know very clearly that you are
not being liberated
and that's the reason why we want to
raise awareness and we want to use the
hashtag
hands off my hijab and what i want every
single one of you guys to do here
is anytime you go past the french
embassy or the german embassy
i want sisters specifically or brothers
with their
partners to come and take a picture
right in front
with your wife we're in the hijab or the
nikah whatever it may be
to make awareness in solidarity with our
sisters around the world
and in the west in the uk thank god we
do not have these laws
but what this shows you is brothers and
sisters that all started off with the
nikah
right it all started off with the nikah
first they said oh no it's not
it's political islam nonsense now it's
come down to hijab
and the question that needs to be asked
is once they come for the hijab and the
hijab
is taking off what else are they going
to ask for this is our concern so
brothers and sisters
we are asking for every single one who
is watching this to raise awareness
to this matter because it is not fair a
woman can and
we hear this a lot a woman can choose
how she wants to dress but the question
is why is that when a muslim woman
chooses to wear a hijab
it becomes a big problem why can't she
choose to wear her hijab
why and allah says in the quran
muslims
the muslim man and the muslim woman the
believing man and the believing woman
the obedient man and the obedient woman
and it goes on allah
speaking directly to our brothers and
sisters but specifically for our sisters
hold tight to your hijab hold tight to
your jilbab and the kaaba whatever you
want to wear
even for our sisters who are trying
their best to wear the hijab the point
is this proven sisters no it's okay
it's okay the point is this what we're
seeing
is that if we keep quiet to this matter
this shows us that they are not going to
stop at that
yeah you give them a finger they're
going to want the whole arm before the
video ends let's ask the two muslim
hijabi woman behind me
if they choose to wear the hijab or are
they forced into it let's go
do you choose to wear the hijab no you
don't
no do you choose to wear the hijab
so so why do you wear it
what about you hold on a second guys let
me get this one let me sit down let me
sit now
so they don't choose to wear the hijab
we thought a lot of muslim women say no
i choose to
prophesy says let's make something very
clear we do not choose to wear the hijab
we are told to wear the hijab by allah
subhanahu ta'ala now you might be
thinking well that's
that's it that's oppression and we say
no you know why we say no brothers and
sisters
because we believe every single woman
and man like a very famous philosopher
said
man is born free but in shackles
everywhere you know what that means
growing sisters for anybody that comes
and says you know what i choose to dress
up
half naked or i choose to dress up in
this way or that way no you don't your
society and the makeup industry and the
beauty industry makes you feel so ugly
that you have to dress in a certain way
to appease that or to appease
the opposite gender whatever it may be
so when anybody comes and says hold on a
second
we choose to do this no you don't
actually because you are subconsciously
made to feel ugly in a certain way that
you have to perform and look a certain
way
why would so many women go and have
plastic surgery and feel ugly and the
makeup industry is a billion pound
industry
why because they want to or because they
feel
insecure so that is our point our point
is
everyone is told to look a certain way
why do you guys have a problem when the
muslim woman or the muslim man
is told by their creator which we should
obey if there's anyone that we should be
following is our creator
to dress up in a hijab or a jibba or a
nikah or a buyer or
a beard and as muslim man to cover our
modesty and know where our gaze is
why is that a problem so here is the
action plan hashtag
what you see underneath here hands off
my hijab
and i want sisters and brothers who
married israel inshallah married
couples to come here in front of the
french embassy in front of the german
embassy
and take a picture with your wife you
can blur their faces if they want to if
they don't want it it's totally up to
them
and hashtag and send it so because
legally if you can see
in the context the embassies are kind of
their soil their grounds so we are here
in the french soil
yeah legally i think that's if i'm not
mistaken and we are telling you get your
hands off
our sister's hijab until next time
assalamu alaikum what happened
ahead